>> Tucker: SAME ONES US
LECTURES ANTIRACISM SUMMIT.
WE FOUND A AMAZING SERIES OF
BLOG POSTS THAT HAVE
RECEIVED NO MEDIA ATTENTION.
THE PERSON WHO WROTE THEM
LOOKS IN RETROSPECT LIKE A
PROPHET CALLING FOR AMERICA
FIRST POLICIES AT LEAST A
DECADE BEFORE PRESIDENT
TRUMP ENTERED POLITICS.
IN THE DAYS AFTER HURRICANE
KATRINA.
THE BLOGGER SUGGESTED BORDER
PAID AMERICANS OUGHT TO
REBUILD THE CITY OF NEW
ORLEANS.
IN 2006, THE BLOGGER SAID
THIS ABOUT HER TELEVISION
VIEWING HABITS, QUOTE:  I
LOVE LOU DOBBS.
HIS SHOW HAS BECOME REQUIRED
VIEWING AROUND MY HOUSE.
THE VIEWER AGREED WITH LOU
DOBBS ON IMMIGRATION.
FLYING THE FLAG ON U.S. SOIL
PRESCRIBES ME AS
PRESUMPTUOUS AND INSULTING
TO THE U.S.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE NOT COMING HERE
BECAUSE THEY EMBRACE OUR
IDEALS THEY COME FOR OUR
MONEY WHEN THEY SEND BACK TO
MEXICO.
SHE MADE A PRETTY CLEAR
HEADED EVIDENCE BASE FOR
THAT IN A 2005 POST.
THE SAME BLOGGER ATTACKED
DEMOCRAT HOWARD DEAN FOR
USING RACIST ANTIWHITE
RHETORIC IN A SPEECH.
QUOTE.
TAGGING THE OTHER SIDE, THE
REPUBLICANS, AS THE PARTY OF
WHITEY MAY SOUND JUST LIKE
THE WAY TO GET THESE
MINORITY VOTERS BACK BUT IT
SO MISSES THE POINT.
THE BLOGGER LATER SCOLDED
HOWARD DEAN FOR INSULTING
CHRISTIANS AND WHITE
AMERICAN.
WHO WROTE ALL OF THAT?
GIVE YOU TIME GUESS BUT YOU
WOULD NEVER GUESS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, IT SEEMED
LIKE THE AUTHOR OF WHAT I
JUST READ WAS JOY REID.
THE NOW TOTALLY DOGMATIC
RACE-BAITING MSNBC WEEKEND
HOST.
ACCORDING TO THE INTERNET
ARCHIVE, JOY REID APPARENTLY
POSTED THOSE VIEWS ON A NOW
DEFUNCT BLACK HAWK BLOG A
DECADE AGO.
MSNBC WOULD FIRE HER RIGHT
AWAY FOR THE CRIME OF
INDEPENDENT THINKING.
WE REPEATEDLY CONTACTED JOY
REID'S LAWYER AT MSNBC FOR
COMMENT AND NO ONE RESPONDED
TO US.
IT'S POSSIBLE REID WILL
CLAIM TWEETS WERE WRITTEN BY
HACKER.
LAST TIME SHE GOT CAUGHT
WITH BLOG POSTS.
MAYBE SHE WILL DO THE
UNEXPECTED AND ADMIT THAT
THERE WAS A TIME BEFORE THE
REVOLUTION CURRENTLY IN